I'm going to talk about why web links
break now I'm sure this is something
that everybody is familiar with and has
annoyed everybody if you're browsing the
web and you're doing it clicky stuff you
follow a link follow another link follow
another link and then all of a sudden it
doesn't work it breaks you get the
dreaded 404 error message it's a best
and annoyance but it can be a major
problem because in the case of old web
sites aren't continually being
maintained and updated it can make them
completely unusable if I've certainly
quite often seen web sites that might
have useful information on but none of
the links work everything gives you a
404 error the reason it's 404 is that
comes from the protocol underpinning the
world wide web it's one of the error
messages and it just means there's a
missing file at one level that might
seem quite trivial somebody's deleted
the page you're pointing at or whatever
but information systems don't
necessarily have to behave like that if
you are browsing through the files on
your PC and you're using Windows
Explorer or Mac finder or whatever and
you move a file you don't suddenly
something error messages because you've
moved a file where as you do on the web
and this comes down to quite a
fundamental way in which the web is
designed and really the problem is that
links on the web aren't actually links
that's all they're missing because if
you think about it for a moment a link
the word link is a metaphor in design
it's taken from the links of a chain and
a link implies that two things are
actually attached if you move one you
can't separate them as not the way the
web bags what you've actually got on the
web is not links at all but pointers
you've got a pointer from one
to another but you don't even have that
you have a pointer from one document to
where you hope another is going to be
and that's my things great let's take a
web page I'll have to just take my
personal web page and a web page to
identify by URL so the URL is this now
if I want to put in a link into that
page I would just put in pulling extra a
which that's an anchor because this is
the anchoring end of the link H ref
equals like that and href just stands
for hypertext reference it's referencing
this web page then I can just put in the
text from the link so click here and
just finish that so that now is the HTML
to create a link but you could see what
it is it's a hypertext reference to this
web page there is no way that this web
page has any knowledge of the fact that
it's being referenced it's if I put a
link into your web page your web page
doesn't know about it and neither do you
unless I tell you as far as the
mechanics of the Weber concerned it's
purely the href it's a pointer to where
something possibly is because it's up to
me when I put it in to actually get that
right and if it was right at the time
but then you change the name of your
document then all of a sudden it's wrong
and this is why the web is very brittle
it's why can break I mean there are ways
around that
but they're not particularly easy a lot
of the web these days isn't just HTML
documents a lot of the web is data
driven and as database underpinning it
and if you're careful enough with the
design of your system you can have a
system that manages its own links
and that will be fairly careful not to
break but eat but for one thing that's
quite hard to do and but the other thing
is that even if you do that the moment
you have a link that goes out to
somebody else's web page you want to
link one of my pages or you want to link
something on the BBC news site or what
have you then the moment that somebody
else outside of your control changes
things it's going to break and that is a
fundamental problem to the way the web
works is because any solution is
retrofitted through the way that the web
work and so I'm afraid although they are
very very annoying 404s are going to be
with us for the foreseeable future and
they're an annoyance that you have to
live with if you use the web
people could create new material a new
content by quoting original sources I'm
taking the original material and putting
it into a new context but an interesting
part of this is Ted also envisaged a
micro charging